[Music]
all right let's do it
just give me a second exciting you feel
asses on glass off whatever you want
okay okay what's your name Kenny who are
you from San Diego so the question is
can you think of a time where you were
moved emotionally by something or
someone and share with us
yeah okay so uh no that's sad
I'd like to pick something happy if it's
about a dog in around over it's really
sad I'm gonna talk about it so I'm
smiling but it's really sad to see that
so I was I know that's also sad okay
good
okay
I'm ready I'm ready to talk about it so
it was about 14 years ago this was very
deeply emotional for me it was late
night it was my sister's birthday
actually I think it was her 15th
birthday and all the adults were having
a good time and they left the side gate
open so the dog had run away from the
party there's too much noise it was my
first pet I grew up with his dog I
raised his dog and it ran all the way up
to the side street it's kind of a busy
street I guess and people drive up and
down drunk Hall and ass pretty
frequently and we heard a loud
screeching sound like tires I guess so
we went up to the road just to check it
out without there's maybe a car accident
or something notice the dog was missing
and everyone started panicking and they
didn't want me to go because I was too
little at the time but I scooted all the
way out there and was like half a mile
away and I saw my dog was still alive on
the side of the road black lab beautiful
she was only a
shoot my eight years old I guess so
she's getting up there but too young too
young for a time and
you know I ran up to her I held on to
her
bawling my eyes out of course I was a
little little one but she died right
there with me on the side of the road
and we had a little funeral for that
night dug a little hole everyone helped
kind of dig one shovelful at a time but
you know it taught me about loss until
then I had no one in my life
do I know family members or anything and
it was kind of the closest thing that I
had felt to losing something important
in my life
and I still think about her almost every
day to this day what was her name
Lucy
[Music]